[Music]
yeah so uh welcome guys um I'm going to
talk about a new way to manage python
environments using pixie and as you said
my name is kin Arts uh who is that uh I
am a previously software developer in
robotics uh environment and uh there we
had a lot of problems with dependency
management so we uh figured out a way to
deal with that that was namely with Kaa
and later I got so enthusiastic about
how our users were um how our colleagues
were using that that I wanted to focus
on that more so I joined prefix to uh to
build that into a product that can we
ship to
everyone so at prefix we make uh
software package management easy and
painless and that's the goal of the
company uh we have multiple different
ways of doing that uh one of which is
Pixie which I'm talking about today uh
our main tools to uh solve this is uh
the cond ecosystem and the rust language
and I will uh explain more about that
later um but I'm going to first go over
some well-known issues that probably all
of you have encountered so uh when you
install uh your system you sometimes
have to have multiple versions of python
on your system and those can just like
scramble together and not work very
nicely and installing them can be pretty
hard that's something we need to fix you
also need to fix breaking installations
so if you have uh pip installed
something on your system and uh you're
doing another project and you need to
pip install something for that those
dependencies might interfere with each
other and you have a broken system
suddenly also uh I'm going to talk about
a lot about being fast because we want
uh you to not have a startup time uh to
get a new project running you want that
to be fast so not slow anymore um also
pseudo access is something that many of
you probably have encountered that you
need some kind of access on the system
that you might not have or you don't
want your application to have pseudo
access on your system uh that's
something you need to get rid of and
then last but not least the
reproducibility of environments so if
you have something created on your
system you're happy everything works you
can debug you can you can start your
service or whatever you need um then a
colleague of you also needs to do that
and then you need to start the whole
process again of getting your
environment set up and that's something
we really want to fix with Pixie so the
three main goals are get started fast uh
build complex environments but in a
simple way and make it easy to share it
with everyone in your team or in your uh
community that you're working with so
the goal is you clone any project or get
the source code of it and you run pixie
run a task in this case start and your
setup is ready and uh everything gets
downloaded everything gets installed and
you can continue your
work so now in a little introductionary
video that we created with the launch of
Pixie that was back in August and uh
hope like
[Music]
it
so uh I hope you got uh any of
that is it
going it's not necessary anymore anymore
yeah thank you so uh I hope you
recognize some of the application that
you saw on the screen and how easy it
was to get all these things working with
Pixie this is something we really think
is important that you can run whatever
you want within pixie uh but the main
pillars are that we are fast so the not
just the actual speed and time but also
the usability of it is uh it feels fast
and you can uh create things uh yeah in
a faster way so you don't get delayed by
reading a lot of documentation pixie can
run the tasks for you and you will get
up and running really fast then
multiplatform is huge so still a lot of
developers are uh developing from
Windows which is not very well supported
for a lot of the Python ecosystem and we
want to pull it back into that space as
well of course we also need Mac and
Linux for servers and other developers
so we want to spread uh the load to
every uh developer um system
and then uh support for K and pip
packages uh we are building on top of
the K ecosystem and that is our main
focus um for you that don't know it it's
a different package uh manager for uh
python packages but more than that and
we also support Pipi uh which you all
know that's being used by pip and poetry
um this is just an alpha release uh last
week actually but we're ramping up that
uh feature as well so you have one tool
that can from both K where you get your
python version and from PPI packages
that you can get any python package and
then we also want pixie to be helpful so
like all the tools that you already know
you probably experienced some pain and
that's something we're really focusing
on that that pain goes away that you
that package management is not something
you have to think about a lot anymore
that it's just an easy going
experience so I know everyone is going
to ask like how does it compare to
everything else so made a very
opinionated and uh not complete list but
I at least want to show a little bit of
like what Pixy will do and uh why we
added it to that uh in in respect to the
other tools that are on the market uh so
K and Mamba are uh both like K package
managers uh just like pixie but uh they
only really do the the package
management itself uh for the rest they
don't build packages or have any kind of
task there are not loog files built in
um they do have versions of lock files
but that's that you need to install that
as an extra and we think it's important
that everything is built into pixie then
speed is it fast uh K just got a little
bit faster because it now uses the
actual Mamba uh solver in the back end
so what Mamba sold for K was that it was
faster now K is doing that as well um so
that's kind of solved but still coma is
not usable without python so you still
need a python version on your system
because it itself is a python uh
application then uh we all know PIP IT
is uh uh yeah everyone knows it but it
doesn't uh install python for you so you
still have to deal with that and um it
does build your packages what K mamb
don't do out uh out of themselves for us
doesn't do a lot because it's uh
notoriously slower than um installing
with K and then you have uh on the other
side uh that's like a super modern
really cool way of installing python
packages I really like it in that sense
uh but it's still a python package
manager just just a python package
manager uh it cannot run uh your
predefined tasks although it has scripts
uh it's not a full task that you can run
in your system and uh uh it does have
log files built in which we think is
really important but we can do all of
these things so we can install python
for you we are going to build pack
packages for you it's not in there yet
but we will definitely be able to do
that later and we have a predefined task
so what you just saw all those things
that we're running with task you don't
have to uh give long list if you want to
start up a server or anything you just
run the predefined task in your
configuration uh we always generate log
files for every uh time you install your
project because the loog fil is
representative of your environment
everything in your environment will be
in your log file and uh that makes it
really easy to share and then it's of
course going to be really fast that's
something we focus on and you can use it
without python so you install it it's
one binary and you can
go then I have a little shorter video
shorter video and simpler video here I
create a environment um with Pixie so
this is what it looks like for you if
you start using it uh so you do pixie in
it and then just the name of a folder of
the project that you're going to do um
it's getting initialized you you go into
that folder that it created and uh I'm
not going to show it on this screen but
there is an configuration file generated
to that configuration file you add
Python and now just installed python for
you and then you can run your python so
we really want this to be on the front
end as simple as
possible and
um you can go to the next slide
um as simple as possible and everything
is going on in the back end I think you
can all agree that this was pretty fast
I do have to say this was cached so this
isn't uh the first time you're going to
run this uh because you're still limited
to how fast you can download stuff to
your system but after the first download
uh we have really aggressive caching
system that will just uh yeah pull
everything from there so your uh system
won't have to download everything every
time uh then why do we use K so for in
the data science that we the timer is
not
started um for in data science uh
Windows support is still pretty hard
because uh without Kai it's it's just a
problem to get uh python on your system
uh so that's really nice uh then for the
machine learning we have great GPU
support because we actually know what
GPU you're running while installing and
locking your system uh for robotics
where I'm coming from it's really
important to have multiple languages
because you do some stuff in C++ you do
some stuff in Python you might have
other languages that you're using you
have a lot of tools that you want to
install and for the robot assist we just
want to have one simple application that
can do it all um and then for cloud
deployment I just want to mention it
here because it can run anywhere so if
you generated it locally you can use
that project put it on the cloud and run
the same exact same uh logic there so
some people will say oh but you have
Docker for that uh yes but you still
need to generate Docker image so how do
you're going to do that for that you can
also use pixie because it's all it can
run everywhere um them some little
history so K started with python it's a
Python program then Mama wanted to make
that faster using
C++ uh then preix started and they we
were like okay uh we like that it's in
C++ our CEO uh Wolf start at Mamba and
he really liked that but uh some of our
colleagues are really really uh good at
rust and already uh knew a lot about it
and
yeah we decided the ecosystem is so
important that we change it to rust and
I'll get a little bit more into that
later so what does a package manager
like pixie do it solves your
requirements so uh it has a solver
mechanism to get the exact puzzle
together of the combinations that you
want for your environment uh normally
you want the highest version so if you
say I want python you want the newest
python say I want python above 3.9 you
get still the highest py Pon because
that's what you normally would want uh
then you install those packages there
are some steps in there but normally
that means you need to download the
actual data and you need to put it in
the correct location and there's some
caching steps in between that then
managing the environment so
some uh tools like AP for uh for Linux
uh stop there but then managing the
environment would uh still be something
that we think is important especially
because of the uh virtual environments
that pick creates you want to interact
with that so uh it creates a lock file
for you that uh States the environment
and you need a way to activate the
environment pixie can also do that for
you um and then of course there's some
helper uh stuff for the developer so you
have authentication that you might need
to do you have uh uploading to uh
repositories that you might have to do
all that logic is also in pixie
um and I want to give that to you then
so solving is a bit of a abstract thing
so you actually are talking about the
Boolean size feedability problem and
don't quiz me on this but uh I think I
understand the basics um what you're
doing is just getting a huge graph of
all the options that you have in your
system and then you want to find the
best path through that graph and uh for
package management this is normally just
the highest version of everything that
can match with each other and uh the
algorithm is just going to see like if
this dependency doesn't work with that
dependency then lose that part of the
part of the graph um and to speed this
even up uh speed this up even more we
use cdcl which means that we learn from
the things that we uh say doesn't work
together and then the gross gets smaller
much faster than you would normally uh
normally have because brute forcing is
just too slow it's it's it's millions of
options that you have uh uh to check uh
I'm not a professional on this uh Boss s
on our team is the best one to ask uh he
did a talk in at packaging con that we
had uh a month back and uh yeah his talk
will go a little bit more in depth on
how that
works then installing a package uh what
does that entail uh you need to download
the data of the package itself you need
to unpack it into the the cach in our
case uh so um the downloading step uh is
something that we really think is
important to parallelize on your system
uh so that's like 20 uh different
packages at the same time are getting
downloaded that is then unpacked into
your cach directory before it's putting
in put into your environment and getting
it into your environment we use hard
linking uh that means that if you uh get
a package into your environment uh we
don't copy the data we only link to it
uh and that makes it first off faster
but also uh better on your hard drive
because you don't want all your data
double
then the pixie toml is the configuration
file we're now working with and this is
what it looks like uh we want this to be
readable and that's why we chose toml uh
you probably all know that by project
toml uh it's the same format uh we're
also thinking about supporting that but
for now we're sticking to our own uh
design uh to make the development easier
uh what you can see is just a project
definition uh with the basic data
something to note is is that we Define
our channels and our platforms also in
this part of the data uh because for uh
K that's there's not just uh one
repository like there is for PPI but you
have uh multiple different repositories
called channels and K Forge is the open
source uh one from K but you can have
for Pythor they have their own channel
and Nvidia has their own channel and on
our website you can also make your own
channels if you want to have them
private or public um you can can add
those to the
list and then for the platforms you
define which platforms you want to run
on so while I was making this I was
running on Windows but uh if you want to
support your project on multiple systems
you just add the systems that you think
your code is going to support uh to this
list then you have the task so you can
simply Define a name and that name will
be available in your uh CLI and then run
any shell command uh that that you would
like uh this can also depend on
different tasks and you can have U much
more options added to this but in the
simplest way it's just this and then of
course your dependencies of your project
requirements some might call it and this
list
uh uh also has some more features like
the target so uh sometimes you want a
different version of python on a
different platform you can Define that
here then the loog file the lock file is
called pixie. loock instead of pixie.
toml and this is one instance of one
package that uh might be in such a loog
file uh in this case it's Babble it's
not per se super important what what you
see here but uh what I want you to
notice is that we go really far in what
we are actually looking so we're not
locking uh I got this package of this
version no on this platform with this
name I got precisely this thing so if
you want to recreate you don't have to
guess a lot of things along the way you
just get that uh file and uh install it
for that platform and this makes it very
reproducible then after that uh you have
your whole installation you have your
environment activation um so that
actually just means adding the the data
from your environment to the path that
you're currently using um which entails
some activation scripts sometimes that
you need to run and uh setting those
environment variables uh ready to use
for instance if you want to build some
C++ you might use cmake I'm not sure if
I I go too far from the python world but
that means that that package that you
installed cake might add some
environment variables to your
environment that pixie wants to start
for you when you start your environment
and also loses when you go back to your
normal workflow of your normal
system uh then as I told you uh last
week we released uh PPI packages so uh
you can Define them in your pixie tomel
as well
uh which means they're also in your log
file thank you um which means they're
also in your log file and uh this is
really important because uh before this
uh K would uh download all the K
packages install that and then add uh
use pip to add P packages on top of that
it's really hard to lck that together uh
we put that uh into one file and uh we
use our own uh resolver for that so
where we built in resolver for cond
packages this now can also resolve PPI
packages and um uh this this is just all
run by Pixie while you uh start an
environment um so why did we choose rust
specifically um now first and uh
foremost we need to say it's fast
because it's rust um then uh that's
actually something we care about because
we do really lowlevel stuff with a
package manager you dealing with a lot
of iio a lot of CPU intensive tasks that
you need to do like unpacking uh uh
those packages um but it's also really
important to us that you have this
single binary uh so you don't need a
package manager to install your package
manager because that's just
bootstrapping it um we want you to be
able to download the file and run that
file and that is our package manager um
you can of course still install it with
package managers we are available on
coma we are available on Brew we're
going to be available on uh more of them
but uh we shouldn't need another system
that we depend on as a package manager
and then the ecosystem is uh really nice
so we have uh awesome libraries for
serialization and deserialization which
we do a lot for all those files that I
was just talking about but also the
packages themselves contain a lot of
files that we need to look into uh
networking there's
uh it's really great for async
networking and uh for file system
there's the standard library that we can
use and there's one extra thing that I
want to mention is that our errors are
uh built using M and that's an awesome
Library where your errors are not just
little strings but they can actually
like display some data from your uh
files so if there's an error in your
pixie tunnel uh it will actually like
point you to which line and then which
word in that in that file it's just
going to help you a
ton then I don't want to go into too
much detail but there is something extra
with package management that I didn't
talk about yet and that is security and
this is also something we are not fixing
yet with Pixie but our company's really
looking into uh and that is uh yeah the
security of your software supply chain
and some notable uh things there are the
signing rebuilding and as bombs and this
is uh have been a big Topic at the
packaging com that we just had that are
company organized and uh I just want to
show you a little bit of uh what that
means for your security within your
software development so signing uh you
all might know the the https where you
actually sign what you're sending
over uh you normally sign with a
certificate Authority that says like you
can trust this signature you can trust
these keys that uh that I provide you
with and for packages that goes even uh
level deeper so you don't just want to
know where it's coming from and trust
that person where it's coming from but
you might also want to trust uh the
platform that is built on so if you have
been building your packages on a AWS
system and you know those dependencies
were on that AWS system while building
then you actually want to know that
about your package and uh signing can
help you like see what uh the like how
you can trust your uh your package that
you're
downloading then rebuilding is really
important like if you do trust the
system uh you can skip this but if you
want to make sure you can trust it you
want to be able to rebuild a package and
that means that uh you want to know the
input that uh the package uh is being
built from you run the build script and
you get a package out of that and if you
give the same input you should get the
same output otherwise there might be
something weird going on with that
actual package that you got so the
hashes might U match but
um uh of what you're downloading but the
hashes don't match if you rebuild it
again so you actually don't really know
what you're installing
um and then there's as bombs this is
being brought up more frequently last
few years uh because a lot of companies
are uh uh making this mandatory and as
bombs is software bill of materials so
you know exactly what is in your
application and you don't uh sorry uh
you know exactly what's in your
application and there's a standard for
this uh called spdx and this is broadly
used so there's more and more tools
coming on the market that can deal with
spdx this is something we also want to
build into our build systems so that you
can um uh see what an environment that
you created with Pixie uh really
includes not just what's in Lo file but
what is used to to build that
environment and then uh what you can get
from that is the security so these spdx
things can be linked to uh the cves that
are online that's the uh vulnerability
uh indexes and then you can check if
your environment might be U having some
issues and of course uh this also makes
it really easy to add identifiers for
your licensing so you can just print out
uh I I have these license on these
projects so uh it's important for
companies to uh to stay safe on
that so uh I think I'm good on time uh
little
recap uh we're building pixie uh it's a
new Fast package manager that's going to
solve a lot of your problems uh by being
fast being a single binary um being able
to install more than just PPI packages
but also lower level uh we don't even
need python if you just want to install
another
project um we utilize rust to improve uh
this ecosystem so you see this much more
um Talk by Richie about polars of course
is also doing this and I think this is
coming up more so if if you're a python
developer and want to use uh a lower
level language uh rust is a perfect
option because it's a little bit more of
a modern way of working than for
instance learning
C++ and package management is not solved
yet uh I was just talking about some
security stuff there's much more that we
can still do to improve this but we're
working hard towards uh a solution for
uh for
everyone it's open source try it out um
it's should be really easy to install
and uh if you have any questions join us
on uh giut Discord and uh I'm happy to
help you with any of your questions and
uh that's it thank you all right thank
you thank you Reuben we have time for a
couple
questions uh thank you for the talk
Ruben also excellent work prefix uh
important work um
so maybe you can help me understand like
what the role of Pixie could be for
libraries because I fully understand it
for applications you want a lock file it
works today it should work tomorrow uh
do you have an idea uh what it what it
can mean for libraries that don't want
to pin anything but uh yeah yeah I get
your question um yeah so when uh when
you're developing you actually using it
as a as an application like you're
developing you probably have some
examples that you're want to try
uh and there it is the normal workflow
was just talking about but if you go uh
a level higher like you want to uh share
your work and uh change some stuff there
the building step is really important
and uh then you would uh generate a
different kind of dependency set that
would uh be probably more broader uh and
that you can use to uh to install for
your uh for your users I'm not sure if
that is
enough
but should uh so I have my pip project
Dr toml and I uh I don't pin I try not
to pin because people want to in install
Solara in their environment um but would
I could I still use like pixie in my R
to say well if you want to develop on
Solara you probably want to use uh the
environment that we got working is that
is that how I should think about it no I
don't per say think that uh what you see
often is that Li don't uh add the uh the
log file to the to the project so that
means that every time you install it you
will uh generate a new environment
that's probably the latest and uh and
then you test that automatically um this
is important indeed when you have users
that want to mix and match your package
with other packages uh but yeah not
adding the loog file as a common way of
doing
this
thanks again for a very nice talk so one
of the situation that many of my
colleagues have is that they start a new
project like every two weeks or so and
then of course to reuse the same
environment this is not very
reproducible it's not nice but it at
least it's possible Right like with
Pixie if they would completely switch to
pixie like they would run out of this
space and similar situations have been
solved like for example in Julie it it
duplicates Al I think p and PM from the
ja
environment also D duplicate is this
something that you've discussed or
considered uh yeah so for the most part
uh growing your pixie environments
doesn't per se grow your uh your dis
usage because of the
caching yeah so currently I think I have
like a hundred on my system including P
torch and stuff like that uh because you
can use the same uh cache files for the
different environments so I only need to
install one version of BU torch maybe
three versions of P torch use them
across different uh environments and
then the the yeah the system is not
impacted that
much thanks I I have a question from a
users perspective often you create your
cond environment and then you install
with cond some packages but then ah also
piie has some packages then you start
installing some from cond some from piie
and in the end that doesn't work how
does pixie solve this problem because
now you support also byby packages yeah
so we have a uh a two-step solver at the
moment uh where first the com packages
are solved kind of the same way you're
describing and then that information is
directed into the the rip solver so the
the PPI solver and uh it uses all of
that information to decide like what is
already com what can I still install
with ypi and then uh that's matched and
it will also fill automatically if it if
it cannot match uh but it will take only
what it needs and um install that for
you we are working however on a better
system for that because right now it's
uh a bit of guessing that you need to do
um and there are some files online that
map Kaa and P Pipi together but we uh we
still have some work on that to improve
the compatibility between those
two we time for one last
question first of all this is so
exciting I need to install it right away
um my question was uh quite often you
get the cannot resolve these
requirements in K right that's kind of
the resing of hell um what happens with
Pixie can you actually then tell me why
hasn't it resolved like where is
basically that wrong PIN that I have to
move because we have that in Julia and I
love it I would love to see that in
pixie yeah so uh uh I'm sad that I don't
have my own laptop so I could show it
but uh what Pixy will do is it will
print out uh uh checks that it tested
and that says like I cannot combine
these packages because I first pinned
this and uh I think we can still really
work on how that is presented to you
because it's just a long list of things
if you have a really complex system but
uh it at least gives you that
information actually I uh because I try
a lot of examples sometimes I just throw
that information in ch gbt and it will
give me some tips and that actually
works so all right let's thanks Ruben
one more
[Applause]
time
[Music]